what's up guys today i have an amazing
video for you where we're going to be
talking about
all of your most frequently asked
questions on the covet 19 vaccination i
brought an amazing guest dr
sima yasmin who's not only a doctor
she's an epidemiologist
a journalist she's the director of
research and education at the stanford
health communication
initiative dr yasmin thank you so much
for being here we're really excited to
have you
i'm really excited thanks so much dr
mike for having me on today
everyone is hearing about the vaccine
when do you think
that we can actually start giving this
vaccine to everybody
outside of frontline healthcare workers
and those who are
over the age specified by the cdc as
of mid to late december we've got two
different covered 19 vaccines with an
emergency use
authorization in the us but more coming
i think
in the next few weeks the point at which
you can start to extend vaccination to
many more people the tens of millions
that we need vaccinated
could be a few months away there are
some projections that it could be around
april time i think saying spring to
summer is fair because bear in mind that
at least for the two
vaccines we have currently available
it's not just a
one and done shot you're having to go
back three or four weeks later depending
on which one you got
and even then it's only one to two weeks
after your second
shot that your body's actually developed
that kind of immunity
that's going to protect you from getting
sick should there be a preference to
which ones our country should be buying
are you allowed to mix the vaccines some
people may get a choice like hey we have
this
buffet of vaccines i think for some
realistically there won't be so much
choice but now i think
when you are told you are eligible for a
particular vaccine i would roll up your
sleeve and go for what's available
we don't have any data on mixing and
matching so that means if your first
shot is the pfizer biontech shot
you should get that as your second shot
three weeks later
if your first shot was the modern one
that should be your second shot four
weeks later
we're still humans errors are going to
be made i just read a press
article of a pharmacist i believe that
was given
multiple doses of the vaccine
accidentally because they didn't know it
came in a multi-dose vial
and things like that are part of real
world applications these things are
going to happen yeah
we shouldn't be set back by one piece of
bad news
and i know the press a lot of times will
do that and make it seem like something
is horrible i want people to know that
some people don't feel very well some
have to take a day off work the next day
if you know that it's less scary going
in
should it happen to you however the flip
side of that is that every single time
someone in the on the planet has had an
allergic reaction to one of these
covered 19 vaccines
it's become a big headline and i
know people that are like oh i'm just
really scared and i'm like hold on
a few million people at this point have
received these vaccines
and about eight i think at my last count
you know less than a dozen
have developed an allergic reaction you
are totally allowed to be scared of that
allergic reactions are scary but all of
them were fine
they got treated and this is the very
reason that you know after you get
any vaccine for the most part you're not
allowed to go home straight away even
though you want to get back to work or
whatever you're told
no please sit in the waiting room for
the next 15 30 minutes in case you have
a reaction
because this vaccine was produced rather
quickly we haven't had
long-term side effect research available
on it simply because the time hasn't
been there is there anything in your
mind that would suggest that there are
serious long-term side effects
if you look at the history of vaccines
and reactions to vaccines
the vast majority if not nearly all of
them
occur within the days after you get
vaccinated
or at most about four to five weeks
after vaccination
so we've got safety data beyond that
amount of time right we've got
at least eight weeks of safety data but
the other thing to bear in mind
is that we haven't just dropped the ball
now that we have emergency use
authorization
of these vaccines we are continuing to
monitor people for years
out and also another thing is remember
we're prioritizing
especially in the uk older people to get
vaccinated
and so we're going to be hearing stories
and i want to give everyone a heads up
of this
of folks saying well my grandad was 85
he got the covid19 vaccine
and then he died the next month the
thing is if you are
in your 80s you have a one in 10 1 in 12
roughly chance of dying in the next year
and so just because you're in that high
priority group to get the vaccine
it might look like increased deaths
occurring in that population
how does this vaccine work and why is it
different
than the flu vaccine or other
vaccinations that we've heard so much
about
so all vaccines are trying to do the
same thing they're trying
to give your immune system a heads up to
be prepared
should you ever be exposed to the actual
virus with these
two mrna vaccines so there's one made by
fisa biontec one made by moderna
they are new technology they're doing
something really amazing
where they're giving your body a little
piece of rna which is the genetic
code that your body needs for your own
cells
to start making little tiny fragments of
this new coronavirus
so your body's not making the whole
virus you can't get the infection from
the vaccine
but your body gets the code to make just
a spike protein
and then by making that protein your
immune system sees it
takes no it's like okay gonna get ready
should we ever get exposed to this
in the meantime that rna that got
injected into you from the vaccine
it disappears quite quickly it's very
fragile reiterating what you said
because it's so important you're not
making the full virus so you cannot get
coven 19
by getting the vaccine the incredible
thing about these newer vaccines
is that they don't contain any portion
of live
weakened or dead virus which is how some
other vaccines work what are the
ingredients of the vaccine
and are they trustworthy some of the
questions i get asked the most are
is there anything toxic in there and is
there aluminium
or aluminum as you would say in the u.s
the list actually of the ingredients in
these vaccines it's publicly available
you can go online and see it
it's quite a short list and there is no
mercury and no aluminium in there and
the important part is just because
there's a chemical name to a substance
it doesn't make it automatically bad or
dangerous
and on the flip side if something is
claimed to be all natural
doesn't mean that it's all safe how
effective do we think this vaccine is
going to be
let's not talk real world let's talk
based on the evidence we have thus far
in the clinical trials in those phase
three clinical trials which was 44 000
people
for the fisa biontech trial and about 30
400 for the moderna trial these vaccines
were found to be very efficacious i'll
say efficacious right not effective
because we're talking about
in a clinical trial but around 94 to 95
percent efficacious
that was way more than we expected
and specifically when we're talking
about those numbers of efficacy
we're talking about the reduced
likelihood of a person
becoming sick with code 19 we're not
talking about a reduced chance of
getting the infection
and therefore a reduced chance of
spreading it to other people
that transmissibility part that question
about
if i get this vaccine am i less
contagious unfortunately the clinical
trials we have so far did not seek
to answer that question that's something
we're going to learn from the real world
how soon after we're vaccinated both
doses
are we considered protected to this 90
95
it takes one to two weeks for your body
to build up that immunity against the
virus
how many people need to get this vaccine
in order for it to be considered like
eradicated
we think about 70 maybe 75
or so of americans would need to be
vaccinated in order for us to achieve
that herd immunity that we talk about
but it's still a big chunk talking about
three out of four people
how much will it cost do i need health
insurance in order to be vaccinated
no cost to individuals whether you are
insured or you are not insured
the vaccines themselves can be quite
expensive but remember the billions it's
cost to get
us here that's largely taxpayer money so
we've paid for these
now it's the government's job to
distribute them fairly
and to make sure everyone who needs a
vaccine can get one what's the official
recommendations
for who should get this vaccine are
there groups that we
recommend shouldn't take it so right now
i'm not seeing too many recommendations
about who should be excluded from
vaccination
there's some kind of gray areas for
example around pregnant women
because unfortunately and i think this
is not great but they weren't included
in the clinical trials and so it means
pregnant women are kind of told
you can if you want talk to your doctor
weigh the risk of infection versus
potential risk of vaccination
and then make up your mind there's not
very clear cut guidance the other
question that comes up is should groups
who are immunocompromised not receive
these vaccines and actually we're saying
you can receive these vaccines because
they don't contain the virus like some
other
different kinds of vaccines do and then
what about children
you know generally they have fared
better with this virus
they are still vectors for it and
potentially can be spreading it when you
don't have that clinical trial data from
children it makes it really hard to say
what you should do for children at large
the good news is moderna
is now recruiting for a clinical trial
for its vaccine
among 12 to 17 year olds so i hope in
the next few months that gives us that
data about how should children be
involved this is so important to state
here
that the reason this uh vaccine is being
recommended for groups 16 and older
is not because we have evidence that
it's harmful
for those who are under 16. it's because
simply we do not have full efficacy and
we haven't tested it in
groups under the age of 16. i think now
is a really good time to talk about
the difference between those who are
truly anti-vaxx
activists or anti-vaccine activists and
those who are vaccine hesitant
because they've heard something they've
read something that's potentially
misinformation or disinformation i'm so
glad you worded it that way as well mike
because i think i try actually not to
use the term anti-vaccine
very much the vast majority of people
who are kind of
a bit worried about these vaccines
they're not what people might call
antibacters they're vaccine hesitant
they're the kinds of folks who are like
yeah my kids got all their childhood
vaccines normally getting my flu shot
i'm just not too sure about these new
ones they seem to have been developed a
bit quickly
those are the people we really need to
be reaching out to and actually
specifically that question about
wait you told me normally it takes about
10 years on average to develop a vaccine
then how could it happen in 10 months
the question should be why does it
normally take
us 10 years to develop a vaccine that's
way too long
what's happened in the last 10 months is
proof of what can get done
how amazing science can be done and what
achievements you get when you have
international collaboration and
literally tens of billions of dollars
thrown at the problem but the other
piece of context is i know this virus is
brand new
but the researchers who brought us these
vaccines
have been working on this kind of
scenario for
years so that university of oxford group
for example
have been working on a vaccine for
pandemic x a
virus potentially that comes along that
is brand new
what they've been working on for a few
years is how do we get 10 steps ahead of
that so that when this
gnarly infection arises we have to do
very little work to make a vaccine
this is an international effort where
everyone is on the same page
we're cutting out a lot of bureaucratic
red tape to put it simply right
like in getting the funding why because
our economy was threatened
anytime you threaten the economy or
money the problem usually gets solved a
lot quicker
in a more efficacious way i think this
antibody conversation has been really
confusing to the general public
because a we can test for the antibodies
we don't know what the cut off is to
know that you're
immune we don't know how long it lasts
we kind of have this arbitrary
three-month cut off the kind of immunity
that you get
from some vaccines can be stronger and
longer lasting than what you get from
natural infection we also don't have
amazing antibody tests some of them are
not the most
specific and the most sensitive so
there's been a lot of confusion around
who's been exposed i've actually had
some debates with fellow physician
friends of mine who
i've basically taken a firmer stance in
saying that i don't see a value for an
individual to go get tested for
antibodies
do you agree i agree whenever you order
a test it's your responsibility to
follow up on the result med school
one-on-one
and also think about what's actionable
we don't have a full understanding here
of
what level of antibodies truly confer
resistance truly confer protection
against this virus so to me
there are still many unknowns it's
interesting from like a theoretical
research perspective to gather that data
now that in terms of telling a patient
what to do or not to do
i don't think antibodies change that
conversation if you have questions about
the vaccine
drop your questions down below if you
have any hesitations drop them down
below
i'm going to be trying to be more active
in this comment section versus others
because i know a lot of folks do have
questions dr yasmin thank you so much
for being here for all the work that
you've done not only with covid19 but
all the diseases you've investigated
where can people follow you where can
they stay up to date well thank you so
much for having me on today
folks can follow me on twitter at dr
yasmin on instagram at dr sima yasmin
thank you for being here and as always
stay happy and healthy
you